jean loup dabadie bonjour bonjour
journaliste scénariste auteur de théâtre
paroli et 31 ans du physique du charme
vise les dames de la sophistication
croix de feu reprochent les envieux une
certaine va être manière de vivre dans
un peu déçu est n'ont pas désarmé non
sophistication d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
remonter dix ans est un bon mot a oui si
la sophistication et implique le
romantisme d'accord une chose qui me
gêne un peu quand même parce que je
n'entends jamais dire du mal de vous
c'est vrai mais c'est parce que vous ne
vous adressez pas la bonne porte ou
mauvaise porte
en tout cas vous avez un nom qui
s'alourdit parce que la qualité a du
poids et votre nom s'alourdit au rythme
des années vous pourriez être ou
d'artagnan ou hasting aclu gentilhomme
florentin vous êtes plus simplement jean
loup dabadie et dont le prénom
il y a déjà beaucoup de tendresse et
vous n'y êtes pour rien mais peut-être
dès le départ et qui vous marqué par et
pour les croisiens vous ne croyez pas si
bien dire à propos du prénom parce que
je me rappelle que la toute première
critique que j'ai eus qui a été publié
dans un journal où j'allais plus tard
faire mes débuts de journaliste qui
était arts arts et spectacles j'avais 19
ans je n'ai de publier un roman qui
s'appelait s'appelle les yeux secs et et
je lis on dit au bout de quelques
semaines de silence du monde entier
autour de ce livre
l'attaché de presse de moniteurs me
téléphonent matin dans ça y est ça y est
il ya une note de lecture noir avait
aucune balise de sa part parce qu'il ne
l'avait lui même pas encore lu alors je
me précipite en survêtement je me
rappelle va courir jusqu'au kiosque pour
acheter pour acheter art et je vois
enfin l'article ne commençait pas comme
ça mais je sais que la première ligne
que je lis c'est avec un prénom comme ça
on se demande si ce garçon croit aller
quelque part je ne sais pas quoi enfin
ou avec un prénom comme ça il vaudrait
mieux ou qu'ils changent de guérir
carrière ou qu'il change de prénom voilà
c'est ça je me rappelle très bien si
vous trouvez qu'il fait des mots
d'espoir nous je n'en sais rien non je
ne crois pas qu'il fasse des mots des
skis très démodé c
de croire que que qu'un nom ou un prénom
puisse nuire ou a porté bonheur à
quelqu'un avant qu'ils se le fasse bon
on va essayer de bien cerner le
personnage il faut rappeler d'abord que
vous êtes parolier et en connaît
beaucoup de chansons celles de reggiani
entre autres oui le petit garçon oui
c'était la première de 2 to enfin là de
la manière de deux mois pour serge la
première de celles que j'ai écrite et
puis et puis et puis les plus juteuses
chansons pour reggiani aussi pour
rédiger vous voulez que je vous parle
des chansons de serge ou des chansons
général rang général enfin pour
évidemment en ce qui concerne celle de
reggiani
j'y tiens tout particulièrement pour
beaucoup de raisons
c'était oui est d'abord eu le petit
garçon et puis cette chanson capelle et
puis une chanson qui s'appelle la
vieille chanson qui s'appelle l'enfant
et l'avion est une autre chanson sur un
label garçons d'ailleurs une chanson qui
s'appelle france l'unoci est une chanson
qui s'appelle de quelle amérique stena
dernier où il ya d'autres interprètes
alors il ya beaucoup oui d'autres
interprètes faut que les 10
michel polnareff avec qui laventure des
chansons a continué avec des chansons
comme tous les bateaux tous les oiseaux
ou les maisons vides ou ou dans les tout
derniers mots d'amour née dans un ice
cream ces terrains vous savez chantait
jean loup dabadie
ah oui oui à une époque il ya un an ou
deux chaque fois que je passais à la
télévision vous en savez quelque chose
et c'était pas très souvent je passais
deux jours d'un tour de chant alors
quand je vais dire bonjour à ma famille
de grenoble où j'ai été élevé on me
présente toujours battu jusqu'en et
notre neveu jean loup de la télévision
chantal les gens grèce comme chanteur à
la télévision à grenoble parce que la
joie de vivre de d'yves robert non agréé
du 2 rue jean rioux l'invité du dimanche
d'yves robert sedra je venais plus
chante une chanson dhabi il ya également
le théâtre d'abord est un échec qui font
le bien connus l'iphone mémorable échec
oui c'est ça échec au sens de fourme pas
pas échec au sens du bonheur parce que
en ce qui concerne des gens comme
avertit jean christophe averty qu'avait
mis en scène cette cette aventure cette
comédie musicale ou sander souffre à
tous les gens qui jouaient dedans et moi
même je crois que nous en gardons un
très très bon souvenir mais évidemment
au stade des recettes the veut dire fin
nous nous souvenions n'allait pas la
banque d autres qui étaient par ailleurs
responsable du spectacle c'était en
effet un échec
ensuite il y à eut admis succès ensuite
un demi succès pour des amis comme vous
admire chèque pour les autres qui
étaient la famille écarlate arles
aquitaine et pierre brasseur oui avec
pierre brasseur françoise rosay lartigou
rosy varte au théâtre de paris une
centaine de représentations inoubliable
en tout cas pour quelqu'un c'est à dire
pour moi parce que c'est là que je me
suis rendu compte que nulle part
ailleurs on ne pouvait avoir la même
qualité d'émotion qu'au théâtre
en fait parce que parce que c'est vrai
que c'est vrai qu'au théâtre espace tous
les soirs quelque chose de différent
en fait jean cocteau était à ces moments
assez farfelue pour prétendre résolument
qu'au cinéma aussi les acteurs je veux
pas la même façon tous les soirs et il
n'a pas totalement tort d'ailleurs là je
viens de revoir le dernier film que j'ai
créé avec le sautel à max et les
ferrailleurs et je me suis persuadé
leurs projections que que piccoli
notamment n'avait pas joué comme à la à
la précédente
on va se battre et très sérieux de te
dire ça je rappelle qu'au théâtre
pendant la famille car là je me suis
aperçu que à partir du moment où il y
avait des des gens vivants qui jouait
devant d'autres gens vivant il se
passait quelque chose de forcément
différent tous les soirs de même façon
que vous n'êtes absolument jamais la
même personne avec avec vos amis avec ce
qu'ils sont moins avec le théâtre c'est
plus vrai les gens de chez vous c'est
je crois que c'est comme andy la vie
c'est très ordinaire de dire ça mais
d'abord je ne suis pas l'ennemi de ce
qui est ordinaire ce n'est pas commun
c'est vrai que c'est une vie de tous les
jours puisque tous les jours il y à des
êtres qui ont vécu dans la journée qui
viennent dans une maison qui change
d'habits qui entrent sur une scène et
qui disent des choses qu'ils ne disent
vraiment jamais la même façon devant dos
des personnes qui ne sont jamais les
mêmes tout les soirs et c'est vrai que
tous les soirs il ya de l'inquiétude
c'est vrai que tous les soirs il ya de
la drôlerie c'est vrai tous les soirs il
y a cette chose qui semble nous manquer
le plus enfin aujourd'hui qui est
l'émotion dont j'ai parlé de l'échec
d'admis succès il ya même un succès
c'est une vision est majeur willy long
voyage heures avec jean poiret et michel
serrault est qui et qui a été grande de
parties de drôlerie je dois dire avec
avec ces deux là avec ses ces deux êtres
très rare parce que vous savez c'est
toujours la non pas là la querelle mais
la question qu'on se pose à partir du
moment où on fait rire son prochain je
me suis aperçu que tous les grands
artistes dits comique entre guillemets
que j'ai pu approcher de bedos à fernand
raynaud en passant par je parle des
français là singulièrement un précédent
se sont toujours l'impression que
quelques diable les désigne du doigt
dans la coulisse qu'il y aura suis là
qu'est tout ce qu'il sait faire c'est
faire rire
vous comprenez comme senna janvier et
comme si c'était une insuffisance dans
la vie je crois au contraire que c'est
un genre noble
là je parle particulièrement des
comédiens et je suis bien placé pour
aimer aussi les comédiens qui font
métier de ne faire pas rire je pense
justement à des films je vous parlais de
max ou du dernier film de le précédent
film de sautet les choses de la vie
un film drôle ça aussi c'est très noble
mais faire rire
je crois que ces gens dont je parle
anciens oui en tout cas c'est une
mission qui je crois que pendant de
noblesse voit que le vraiment le rire
leur particule si vous voulez et leurs
particularités et quand on dit qu'après
elles sont sont des gens très angoissée
très inquiet comme à moi il m'arrive
plus qu'à mon tour de de l'être quand je
travaille
eh bien je crois que ça s'explique parce
que parce qu'on n'a jamais apprécié
qu'on fait rire avec bonne conscience
vous avez écrit des sketches de doses de
nier qu'ils ont bien marché
oui oui ça fait aussi du gal vous êtes
le plus fier bien
vous savez ce n'est pas je crois pas que
ce soit la fierté qui soit en question
il y à un livre absolument merveilleux
d'un d'un auteur tellement admirable que
c'est jean paul sartre et si je le cite
ce n'est absolument pas pour m'asseoir
sur un tabouret à côté de lui mais pour
vous dire ce qu'il disait dans ce petit
qui s'appelle les mots des mots et une
réflexion sur sa fonction de décrire et
il avance je dis que je suis très
sensible au ridicule d'après de revenir
au sketch a pas d'avoir parlé de
chercher mon mon explication dans dans
ce livre de ça mais c'est parce que
c'est une leçon pour tous les gens les
petits et les grands les modestes et
orgueilleux qui se mêlent d'écrire et
dont beaucoup se vante sans l'être
d'être d'être des écrivains dans les
mots donc sartre dit vous ne pouvez pas
savoir le plus grand plaisir que vous
pouvez me faire que l'on peut me faire
le plus grand plaisir que l'on peut me
faire c'est de me dire que la plus belle
page que j'ai jamais écrite est
précisément la dernière que enfin ce ne
sont pas ces termes exams sait ce qu'il
veut dire
il nous laisse entendre que si on
rencontrait
sartre et qu'on lui dise à la nausée à
et que ça lui apporterait quelques des
plaisirs
alors qu'en revanche si on lui parle de
son dernier article des temps modernes
ou de là on le rend heureux comme comme
un enfant qui revient de l'école et qui
a eu la moyenne
et ça c'est une c'est une leçon à la
fois de modestie pour tout le monde et
autant c'est une leçon d'amour parce que
quand vous parliez de fierté il ya n'y a
qu'un mot qui explique comment et
pourquoi les gens écrivent quelles que
soient les choses qu'ils écrivent
c'est l'inquiétude en fait alors bien
sûr si vous parlez alors là je fais une
ellipse bien insolente comme la part
d'un mais quand donc parle tant de
choses comme des sketches de bibelots
écrivent pour lui que je peux écrire
pour lui et pour lui pour sophie et bien
c'est toujours le dernier qu'on préfère
du moins je rêve que ce soit le dernier
qui fait le plus rire et et notamment
les derniers qu'on a fait à ce qu'ils
ont créé à bobino je crois si vous
connaissez saint tropez
c'est le dernier cri pour glisser saint
tropez précisément il un politique un
peu dans tous ses sketches quoi ils
bientôt litige un peu d'angoissé du
présent et de la politique dans votre
mail
je me demande si vous n'y pensez pas
d'un homme c'est à dire qu'on aura
beaucoup entendu dire depuis des années
ce n'est pas faux que la politique est
dans tout et tout est dans la politique
maintenant je serai ça va certainement
tout cas ça m'amuserait beaucoup ça me
rappellerai certaines choses qu'on me
montre ou où se niche la politique dans
les soit dans le cadre de la polémique
le cas de la polémique en a beaucoup ah
je croyais voulait dire un sketch sur la
polémique non kate j'ai forcément de
l'appeler mais assez vrai nom mais je
veux dire si dès l'instant que l'on
parle de son père ou de sa femme c'est
de la politique et je ne nie pas que ça
en soit ça puisse en être bien sûr ou là
par exemple j'ai écrit pour eux
justement en parlant de sketches haskell
sur le téléphone on peut y voir de la
certainement de la politique aussi ou
sur l'hôpital enfin ce que j'appelle
visite aux malades pas y voir on voit
comment on y voit de la politique c'est
dire mais c'est comme ça par exemple on
peut
est-ce qu'on peut plus tout c'est
parfaitement normal oui oui non non non
mais d'ailleurs je ne cherche pas à ce
qu'on m'en excuse mais je veux dire vous
ne croyez pas qu'on y voit surtout un
parti pris de de biffer une fois pour
toutes ce qu'on nous disait à tous quand
on était petit et à quoi obéit sans
comprendre à savoir quelque chose avec
lequel on ne plaisante pas c'est
exactement ça c'est un bon résumé à la
wii en fait il n'ya que des choses avec
lesquelles on plaisante et que des gens
avec lesquels on ne pourront plaisante
d'autant que jamais on nous interdit de
présenter sérieusement non nous avons
parlé de la chanson des sketches du
théâtre mais il ya également une autre
discipline c'est le cinéma il y a les
choses de la vie vous êtes le scénariste
de ce très beau film de claude sautet
il y a le dernier et lien il faut
rappeler les milices armées
il ya max et les ferrailleurs qui va
sortir ces jours ci il ya max et les
ferrailleurs qui sort mardi prochain et
qui est encore à sauter qui est un film
de claude sautet tirer
d'un livre d'un grand auteur qui est
vraiment alors je n'en parle pas pour
pour être venu ici c'est bien c'est le
moteur non mais ça vraiment je veux dire
pourquoi parce que moi j'ai découvert
cet auteur c'est claude néron j'ai
découvert cet auteur lorsque claude
sautet m'a dit eh bien voilà pas les
choses de la vie on va faire un livre
d'après un d'après max et les
ferrailleurs qui est un roman de claude
néron alors vous allez dans ma librairie
et j'ai demandé ce livre j'ai demandé
aussi l'autre livre qu'avait écrit clown
ayrault a écrit deux romans et ce
premier livre vous jacques en tant que
journaliste vous avez peut-être en
souvenir mieux que moi c'était la grande
parade dans ta mère qui a failli avoir
accueilli des bois au concours il ya
quelques années
bon et j'ai fait la découverte d'un très
très très grand romancier vraiment je
vous assure que je ne gaspille ni les
adjectifs ni les superlatifs et je
trouve qu'on doit être très jaloux de
ses amitiés de ses admirations et il
s'agit de quelqu'un
que sa modestie a toujours enfin jusqu'à
présent obtenu dans l'ombre
c'est un homme de plus de 40 ans et
libraires sont l écoute qui a abondé
j'en suis très très heureux parce que et
vous voyez je ne dis pas ça spécialement
à propos de max et les ferrailleurs car
du point de vue du roman si l'on veut
mon avis je préférerais encore la
grand'mare a dit heureusement précédente
qui est un robot sens du mot et au
meilleur sens français du moine énorme
livre bon max et les ferrailleurs est un
livre plus efficace déjà plus matinée de
d'habileté d'auteur d'écrivains plus
matinée même et et personnellement et
sans s'emmêler si j'ose dire
pour max et les ferrailleurs je préfère
le film de claude sautet aux livres
deux polonais rend jeudi donc pas cela
systématiquement pour cloner rond mais
je dis que ce romancier est quelqu'un de
très important que j'engage tous le
monde à lire car pour qui aime les
histoires pour qui aime les histoires
racontées avec cette violence et cette
véhémence qui ne peut trouver sa source
que dans un certain une certaine langue
quand nos amis et quand même mis à notre
disposition à notre naissance et bien il
faut où il faut visiter cet auteur
important alors mais vous me parliez du
film jean loup dabadie vous avez 31 ans
vous avez quitté le journalisme un jour
parce que vous avez voulu vous libérer
parce que vous avez voulu faire des
choses qui vous intéresse et parce que
vous n'oubliez pas être esclave d'un
quotidien de l'hebdomadaire ou d'un
mensuel est ce que ça a été difficile
est ce que c'était un choix à faire
oui c'était un choix c'était extrêmement
difficile pour une raison d'abord très
normal c'est que quand on travaille dans
un journal on est sur deux en tout cas
de vivre tandis que lorsqu'on va
s'enfermer dans sa petite chambre en se
disant ils vont voir ce qu'ils vont voir
des personnes vous êtes la seule
personne à vous être engagé
je veux dire au sens au sens
hiérarchique du mot vous avez dédié sur
devant une autre salle directeur
absolument pas j'étais sûr de ce que je
voulais mais je n'étais pas sûr de moi
serait de treize outre puis dans perso
vous avez même les je crois que même les
jeux parmi gens qui crient même les plus
vaniteux les plus ambitieux je n'en
connais pas qu'ils soient sûrs d'eux il
ya ceux qui affectent de l'être mais
comment l'être c'est un homme et de
toute manière le jeune homme nostalgique
que vous étiez avait une certaine
assurance
le oui va il en faut sans doute pour
dire moi je
je pense que je peux arriver à vivre
sans aller chercher un bulletin de
salaire à la fin de chaque mois
je peux arriver à vivre de droits
d'auteur même si les droits d'auteur
arrive longtemps après et que lancre or
était sèche
oui il faut certainement beaucoup
présomptions mais je veux dire c'est
c'est une présomption qui est
indispensable dans la mesure où la façon
je vous dis qu'on veut aucun auteur ce
n'est n'est sûr de son succès du moins
en fait du succès qu'il qui lui est
éventuellement promis je crois qu'il est
nécessaire qu'un auteur crois qu'il a
raison d'écrire qu'il a raison de faire
ces choses là parce que vous vous rendez
compte d'air c'est une chose que d'un
personnage dont je rêve un jour ce pas
si on peut le situer sur une scène ou
dans un film est vraiment l'auteur qui
vivrait de sa plume en étant son premier
détracteur semblait sincèrement parce
que j'ai beaucoup de types qui disent
oui lissage et que ça ça vaut rien mais
c'est vrai ce sera seulement ils ne
croient pas en fait
mais je reviens d'un type qui est d'un
d'un personnage qui soit tellement
complexe et que ou qu'il éclate de rire
en
ces ordres aux dépens en non au fur et à
mesure que sa plume cours sur le papier
ou qu'il soit complètement navrés et
consterné en disant c'est pas possible
que j'écrive des choses pareilles c'est
comme on est ya certains comédiens comme
ça qu'ils jouent en se trouvant très
beau est-ce qu'il ya parfois du cynisme
chez vous oh ben oui je vous aussi chez
tout le monde j'ai bien sûr chez chacun
d'entre nous il y a un mélange qui est
extrêmement mal dosé parce que il dépend
d'une espèce de météorologie spirituel
un mélange de d'émotion de cynisme de
tendresse de formidables égoïsme et
alternant avec 1 1 un altruisme -
dévouement à des des choses à des causes
voit des gens dérisoire
oui oui mais je crois que surtout qu'il
faut nous nous apercevons tous les uns
vers les autres que enfin où le dessin
avec les autres que coco qu'aucune de
toutes ces personnes qui participent de
ce métier public sent bon les
journalistes les comédiens les auteurs
le metteur en scène les tous ces gens
tous ces gens qui peuvent venir vous
voir ici ou qui semble avoir plus d'amis
ou du moins plus connaissance vivante
que les autres qu'aucune n'était
exemplaire et c'est la chose la plus
touchante du monde et la plus
intéressante vous voyez je veux dire par
là que moi j'ai dès dimanche entier
gâchée par des matchs de rugby ce qui
est une situation quelquefois tout à
fait ridicule par rapport aux
responsabilités que je peux avoir dans
la vie ou aux ambitions qu'à ce moment
là je poursuis dans mon métier et
d'écrire quelque chose de réussir c'est
du temps perdu
non mais on peut juger ça comme vous
comme du temps perdu cela n'en est pas
pour moi parce que l'instant est
tellement formidable je me rappelle
justement ma bonne ville de grenoble la
dent nous est de grenoble
oui enfin non je suis de paris mais j'ai
vécu quelques années à grenoble ou mais
quand parents m'avaient été levée alors
il ya une équipe de rugby que je suis
depuis toujours la paillade ans dans
l'équipe des garçons
taki chalet en classe bon ça c'est parmi
les vieux parce que quand même 32 ans
pour jouer au rugby ça fait rêver non
mais refait ses instincts ménages pour
les avants quand même bon et bien je
peux vous dire que certains certains
jours où grenoble joue en déplacement
des matches difficiles où certaines
années où ils ont du mal à ce qu'elle
fait pour essayer de finale je vous jure
que plus rien ne compte que ça plus rien
ne compte que ça et et s'ils perdent
tout ce qu'il perde salmon ce qui arrive
je veux dire les vilains match
j'ai ma soirée gâcher la vie des gens
autour de moi gâchette serment là je
parle du rugby où c'est la même chose
pour une pour une partie de tennis ou
pour quelque chose car j'ai compris les
jets thoniers grenoble moi je soutiens à
bagnères de bigorre ont protesté
rencontre entre coutras à peu nous
pouvons vous êtes rencontrés une
première fois radioscopie pu vous
retrouver en huitièmes de finale ce qui
est très possible parce qu'il fait tel
que va être fait le tableau est pas
impossible qu'ils tombent les uns sur
les autres et je m'aperçois qu'il ya un
climat est un auteur de théâtre parolier
et scénariste doit avoir cette île où
est mon avis ça sa petite musique
intérieure sa propre ligne mélodique
ah oui oui mais ça c'est certain une
expression que je prendrais volontiers à
mon compte il s'agit en effet d'une
ligne mélodique et si vous voulez c'est
pour ça que c'est quelquefois on dit on
emploie ce mot je trouve un petit peu
absurde pas par mon métier que mode de
dispersion parce que j'écris des
scénarios de film des chansons les
pièces des arbres des roseaux lorsque ça
bon mais je crois que c'est très très
fort parce qu'il s'agit exactement du
même métier
on se sert du même porte plume c'est la
même personne qui s'en sert et d'une
certaine façon les choses sont vraiment
écrite de la même encre et je dis ça en
le croyant de tout mon coeur et en
pensant aux choses qui semblent
tellement opposées que sont deux choses
comme comme le petit garçon avec son
climat où le travail que nous avons
fin avec claude sautet sur les choses de
la vie d'après d'après le roman de
guimard certes des des climats disons
tragique en fin d une clim en tout cas
serrée et rigoureux s'il on appose sa si
l'on met à côté j'ai pas le vison
voyageur ou certaines choses de de bedos
je sais qu'il s'agit du même esprit je
dirais même puisque vous avez dû
remarquer combien dans notre vie
constamment une chose qui nous fait qui
nous fait rire tout de suite on peut se
dire mon dieu ce que si on était l'autre
ou si on était celui avec qui l'on rit
ou des tons gris comme c'est triste
quelle détresse bon en face et le fameux
la famille thème de réflexion sur le
vaudeville hôtel à la régie la mise en
scène les costumes tout ça il s'agit
quand même de situation très tragique
enfin les choses les deux sinistres
les gens qui se trompent donc ils
s'aiment plus assez pour pour s'être
fidèles et qui se font de la peine mais
leur peine s'exprime par des cris et des
cris qui font rire dans la salle c'est
une image de la détresse formidable
enfin poignante
bon c'est la fameuse histoire d'avoir
envie de rire en termes entamée mais
inversement
enfin je veux dire inversement donc il y
à une navette de l'esprit entre les
choses drôles et les choses émouvante et
je crois que les gens sur les comédiens
soient les auteurs ou les metteurs en
scène ne doivent avoir la masse est
floue et suffisamment ambigu pour
hésiter entre ces choses là
avez vous remarqué que dans des
projections de films très de films assez
durs assez rigoureux dès qu'il y à un
mot de dialogues un peu moins serrés que
l'autre un mot même pas plaisantin la
salle éclate de rire c'est vrai car elle
se soulagent collectivement par ce rire
là elle a envie de rire parce qu'on
était sérieux depuis un moment
est ce que vous faites des concessions
au public lorsque vous écrire une
chanson par exemple est-ce que vous
pensez que pas mal est ce que vous dites
ça je sais que ça va plaire je vous jure
bien que je ne me dis jamais je sais
mais je me dis souvent je voudrais
bonjour je voudrais je me le dis souvent
je me dise je me dis quelquefois je
crois je pense que oui il ya des choses
qui sont hélas pas beaucoup mais y'en a
qui semble être mécanique
c'est pourquoi quand je disais que c'est
le même esprit c'est la même école qui
vous fait aller du sketch à chansons de
jean son théâtre du théâtre au roman du
roman au cinéma et aller retour etc
on s'aperçoit qu'on retrouve les mêmes
les mêmes exigences
la même mathématiques pour ceux qui
croient qu'il y en est une moi je n'y
crois pas vraiment en tout cas une sorte
s'il y avait un tant soit peu de
technique qu'elle se trouverait là c'est
à dire que les sketches se montrent
comme de petits réveil particulier on
sait qu'une phrase douar que que le
ressort d'une phrase doit être quand je
voudrai connaitre le terme d'horlogerie
mais en tout cas pampelune terme bâtard
serre est verrouillé de telle façon que
le ressort se détendent en fin de 2
de telle façon que les gens en principe
doivent rire là qu'il nous faut une
vraie mécanique
oui alors là en fait tous les gens qui
connaissent bien le théâtre qui
travaille depuis bien avant moi doivent
se dire ce jeune homme est en train de
grand coup des pôles d'enfoncer toutes
les portes que nous avons ouverte depuis
longtemps peu importe injures tous les
uns derrière les autres
il faut qu' il vaut mieux enfoncer pour
toi des portes fermées et qui ne
s'ouvrent pas de vous rappeler ces deux
critiques qui était d'ailleurs un
hommage je lu ça quelque part ce matin
jean loup dabadie a une belle plume la
manière de s'en servir et la tête à tous
et touche bien oui mais ça n'est pas du
tout la dispersion n'ont jamais faire
comme choses à la fois d'abord oui oui
la dispersion c'est la tête à n'importe
quoi et la dispersion c'est vrai que si
dans la sexy dans la même journée ou
dans la rue ou à la même époque présent
je sais que bon l'année dernière j'ai
écrit est l'adaptation d'une pièce que
fitzgerald fait de la seule pièce que
scott fitzgerald a écrite qui s'appelle
en anglais vegetable une pièce que jean
pierre grenier va mettre en scène à la
rentrée et et bien pour écrire 7.77
cette adaptation je suis parti me fermer
quelque part
non pas pour pour ne pas être dérangé
comme on dit puisqu'au contraire je
trouve qu'il faut être dérangés pour
pouvoir bien écrit avoir des idées ce
seul échange et c'est l'uruguay pour
pour n'être pas du tout en tout cas
tenté de me mêler de à propos où en est
le tournage du film qu'on vient de finir
ou et les chansons et sait pas écouter
les chansons des autres et
éventuellement les miennes à la radio et
c'est bon quand j'ai
et achever ce travail je rentre à paris
nous avons travaillé sur max et les
ferrailleurs avec l'eau de néron et
claude sautet
quant à eux max et les ferrailleurs
était terminée je suis parti dans une
autre maison aime beaucoup de maisons
différentes pour ça pour travailler sur
des chansons
après les chansons j'ai très organisé
non non non non non non non non pas du
tout est-ce pas être organisé que de
faire qu'une chose à la fois non est ce
pour vous installer dans la notoriété
que vous êtes allé à la quête de temps
de forme de divertissement
qu'est ce qui se passe ainsi je vous
répondais oui là par exemple je dirais
oui peau d'un nom alors non c'est pas ça
mais je rêve que fouad et en tire
comment ces caisses qui dit cfcc franc
de nuit en france pour m'installer dans
là n'autorisait pas vaniteux de vouloir
installer la notoriété c'est un non mais
je rêve qu'on a envie de travailler
c'est justement que je ne pense pas que
la question se pose vraiment dans la
mesure où si
niche en civil etc le cher vieux copain
qu'on évoque toujours quand on veut et
n'ont cédé des idées depuis longtemps
reçu après a dit que que 9 ans
n'existait pas tant qu'elle n'était pas
publiés bon c'est vrai donc si vous
écrivez c'est pour publier
quelle que soit la chose que vous
écrivez à partir du moment où elle est
publiée
vous ne me présenterai pas à une seule
personne un seul auteur un seul écrivain
qui vous disent j'ai publié pour qu'on
ne lisent pas ou pour vous je fais un
système de personnes alors j'aimerais
essayer dakhil janin qu'il vienne lui
donc si vous voulez la question ne se
pose pas qui si on fait un métier public
qui se présentent au public pour que ce
public que lui tourner le dos personne
de là à dire que l'on écrit que pour
flatter l'égo de ce public quel qu'il
soit layana l'immense fossé dans lequel
je ne mangerai absolument jamais
voyez-vous jean loup dabadie je suis
bien obligé de procéder que vous êtes un
peu un seul ankara a certainement vous
dit l'hostis aux herbes de provence
mais il ya de l'ironie dans l'air mais
c'est bien servi oui il faut dire que
nous ne crois pas qu'il y ait un seul
auteur qui ne puisse travailler sans la
passion des comédiens car au fond je ne
dis pas évidemment que le moitié de la
moitié du travail soit soit accompli
quand on sait pour qui on écrit mais il
est absolument certain que les
interprètes ou qui vous choisit souple
ont choisi ou avec lesquelles on on
s'entend sont d'une certaine manière
hauteur des choses que nous là nous nous
venons de le voir avec claude sautet
pour max et les ferrailleurs et avec
l'aude néron quand on travaillait tous
les trois sur cette adaptation sur ce
scénario
le fait de savoir que c'était michel
piccoli qui jouerait mac de savoir
c'était romy schneider qui jouerait les
lilas prostitue financier à la grèce en
a mais c'est évident de dire qu'il y à
des sites et des rôles pour eux neely a
même pas d avenir même pas des répliques
mais il y à des scènes qui me semble
absolument gouverner par le parlent par
le fait que c'est tel ou tel interprète
qui c'était la même chose pour les
choses de la vie
absolument oui exactement la même chose
pour choses de la vie
je crois que michel la présence de
michel piccoli avant qu'il soit présent
a été déterminante pour beaucoup de
choses surtout vous savez c'est
absolument passionnant de voir
travailler sautait au niveau d'un
d'inscrites déjà enfin avant même
souvent on pense toujours à surprendre
les audi sauter aujourd'hui il y a deux
ans miller et a dit c'est bien la preuve
qu'il est d'installer l'audi r10 oat et
celui je crois qu'il n'aimerait pas ce
mode d'installation ce que lui non plus
n'est pas de ces gens qui se croient
installés mais qui en tout cas si des
six déjà une certaine façon un certain
style ou ceux non pas s'installe mais
mais fait son chemin c'est je crois
c'est tout ce que l'on souhaite et tout
ce qu'il souhaite et je disais quand
toujours on pense à fait un film et
faire des reportages sur les metteurs en
scène sur leur plateau en train de
tourner ce qui est passionnant
moi je sais que mon métier d'auteur
scénariste me permet de les voir
travailler dans des moments tellement
formidables qui sont l'élaboration du
film qu'ils vont tourner sur ce plateau
c'est à dire le scénario car aujourd'hui
j'ai le meilleur travail
non non je ne dis pas que ça ne m avait
en tout cas c'est celui auquel le moi
j'insiste parce que j'y participe
et que ces groupes il n'y avait pas
at-il d'une époque où le
scénariste parce qu'on appelait le
dialoguiste d'autrefois s'enfermer dans
sa maison comme était une adaptation
dialoguer il apportait un à ce qu'on
appelait un réalisateur à l'époque
réalisateur tourné le film bon après
quelques discussions quelques
modifications quelques objections sert
maintenant les choses se passent
heureusement pas du tout comme ça ou
bien un metteur en scène fait tout c'est
à dire qu'il écrit et tout et on n'a pas
toujours eu à s'en plaindre
voir enfin beaucoup de gens ou bien ils
travaillent avec
inventeur ou des auteurs c'est le cas de
claude sautet et c'est un spectacle très
formidable serait trop long de raconter
et claude au travail ici mais je veux
dire simplement parce que je pensais pas
ce que vous parliez de des comédiens et
de leur influence sur nous avant que
nous en ayons sur eux en fait on parle
toujours de direction d'acteur mais
c'est très amusant de penser que les
comédiens sans savoir fond de la
direction d'auteur ou la direction de
metteur en scène avant avant avant qu'on
se rencontre et claude est quelqu'un qui
sait absolument à la perfection
comment un comédien peut entrer dans une
réplique entrer dans un mot et en sortir
comment il le dire est ce qu'on entendra
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il fait
déjà une ligne est une erreur il fait
abstraitement j'allais dire comme un
travail d'ingénieur du son d'avancé je
me rappelle que vous savez les scènes de
l'accident dans les choses de la vie
bon alors j'écrivais certaines phrases
du de ce qui n'était pas vraiment le
comment faire quand il était dans l'air
vous savez que c'était à moitié une voix
intérieure est bon et qu'il y avait en
même temps des images que l'on décrivait
aussi est qui et qui tenait qu on devait
voir pendant qu'on attendait cette voie
je me rappelle que c'était ça se passait
chez moi claude relisais à l'essai ces
phrases du moribond enfin de pierre le
héros de dans l'herbe en train de mourir
il est il est relisais en se mettant les
doigts dans la bouche en se couvrant la
bouche avec la main en essayant de les
rendre inaudible pour voir ce ce quelle
émotion à l'esprit au coeur à l'oreille
à vous a rien du tout ce qu'il en
resterait les bribes qui pouvait rester
dépouillés de leurs sens et 13 un peu
dépouillés d'une en fin de prêt d'une
partie de leurs sont même pour voir ce
qu'il en resterait dans la bouche de
michel piccoli et gisant dans l'air vous
parler de tout cela avec amour
faire ce métier il n'y avait pas de
l'amour ah oui oui ça c'est absolument
certain d'ailleurs moi je crois aussi
une autre chose c'est que les décrivant
par les auteurs sont en même temps des
décos médias rentrée des metteurs en
scène rentrée des chantres rentrée
jamais rater des 6,6 pour gratter les
choses là la porte aussi grande ouverte
mais on vit forcément dans la passion de
ces choses de la passion de ces de ces
gens ce n'est pas toujours une passion
très pur d'ailleurs je ne le crois pas
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas que
quand quand j'aime tout le fait ou ses
comédiens ou metteurs en scène avec qui
je vais être en train de travailler à
tel moment où de tels moments
je ne suis pas sûr que cc c'est un
simple amour pour leur personnalité
c'est sans doute un amour pour ce qu'ils
sont capables de le faire de me donner
de prendre de ce que je leur donne enfin
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est en
partie un plus est-ce qu'on fabrique et
met les bien sûr est-ce que c'est par
fidélité que vous ne travailler que pour
guy bedos
je parle de 10 au niveau du sketch pour
le sketch oui pour les les autres
disciplines d'écriture c'est pour des
choses mais les veut dire par exemple le
sketch c'est vrai que je n'ai en fait je
ne
depuis l'époque où je faisais de la
télévision on faisait les réserves y
avec averti je n'ai plus fait de
sketches mais comme guy
et non seulement un grand ami jamie mais
plus de ça je crois vraiment un grand
artiste
il n'y aurait vraiment aucune raison que
lorsqu'il me demande un skate je ne lui
fasse pas donc là c'est une fidélité qui
va de soi si vous voulez
elle a été la trajectoire
brigitte et au foyer du soldat à tarbes
au japon refusé mon service militaire et
l'a vu dans une émission qui passaient
tard le soir émission d'avertis
d'ailleurs qui est de michel arnaud qui
s'appelait l'histoire de ceux de sourire
et il disait un sketch qu'il avait écrit
lui-même est une sorte de petit jeune
homme de jeunes comédiens au festival de
cannes et vous l'avez trouvé très drôle
et et je me rappelle le dimanche suivant
l dimanche on est on est libre mais on
était consigné alors dans la chambre et
j'avais écrit 2 enfin un dimanche un
sketch à dimanche faute ça a été le
premier savait pas été bonne elle prête
d'ailleurs c'était le boxeur suarez bon
que je lui avais envoyé par la poste
et puis après bonn fait pour l'être
enfin on débat on s'est connus vraiment
par par correspondance est ce que vous
trouvez jean loup dabadie que la chance
soit changée ce qu'il y ait encore une
chanson d'amour en france ah oui mais en
mai vous trouvez qu'elle a changé pas du
jeu n'ont pas dû toujours qu'elle se
pose la gestion non elle s'est enrichie
à la trouver d'autres mots à vous parler
simplement des mots we know mère
justement je ne crois pas qu'on est
quand on voit qu'on soit très juste
en isolant les mots de la musique la
musique d'un certain style
d'interprétation et un certain style
d'interprétation d'un certain goût ou
d'un ou deux certain goût au pluriel du
du public
ce que je crois oui j'entends souvent
notamment dans vos émissions de
radioscopie il m'est arrivé d'entendre
des gens du métier de music-hall enfin
la radio des chansons se poser cette
question qui franchement me semble ne
pas se poser ce qui se passe c'est que
comme l'est moyens d'écouté enfin
audiovisuels ont dit
à ce soir voilà se sont multipliés comme
les radios sont à la fois plus
nombreuses et mettre plus longtemps
comme on vend de plus en plus de disques
comme il n'ya plus en plus de groupes de
chanteurs dans le monde entier
il y a de plus en plus de style et à
chacun de choisir mais vous voyez bien
maintenant un chanteur bon comme
reggiani à chanteurs comme félix leclerc
je ne suis pas aller l'entendre chanter
à bobino mais il enchante énormément de
gens et je ne crois pas qu'ils en
fassent dans le dans une avant garde
le set se faire une place au soleil par
par des moyens qui ne soit pas classique
si vous voulez c'est un classique
brassens est bon et puis il ya
aujourd'hui en angleterre des gens de
bonne foi qui vous disent que cet
heureux que les beetle se soit séparé
parce qu'ils sont démodés aujourd'hui
l'heure linkstone hausse
leurs liens sont aussi essentielle pole
d'affilée des modèles à michel polnareff
c'est un à mon avis hein
un extraordinaire artiste a proposé tout
les sens du mot extraordinaire et c'est
avant tout je crois lui même tient
lorsqu'on pense à un grand compositeur
un grand musicien
vous savez comment on peut dire que
michel legrand comme on dit mais on en
train de bouger le grand un grand
musicien un grand compositeur
michel polnareff en est un autre et
c'est en plus de ça quelqu'un qui est
est un artiste pour prendre aux siennes
c'est mou tout ce jargon moderne
polyvalent
parce que si vous voyez enregistré pour
une aref c'est lui qui est à la console
comme on dit enfin qu'ils se mêlent de
ses mixages il va surveiller ses disques
jusqu'à la gravure je ne vous parle pas
du travail fantastique qu'il fait du
point de vue de l'orchestration sur
toutes ces musiques et pour lui vous
avez écrit nos mots d'amour oui c'est
une des dernières jean loup dabadie
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes un
benjamin comblée par la vie capable de
rougir
oui oui ça c'est vrai oui appelable
d'être séduits par une jolie femme
mariée je me rappelle que c'était ma
mère quand je n'aime pas quand j'étais
petit mais déjà quand j'étais un peu
plus grand mais vous êtes toujours
remarqué ça quand je me mettais à rougir
alors qu'en cd dans les jambes me le
disait en anglais amusé sur youtube
lashing et a pris comme ça ça va lui
dire tu en train de rougir pour je me
ressaisisse il suffit évidemment qu'on
vous dit ça pour vous devenir ou jc
encore oui oui c'est une bonne chose
oh non c'est l'asse la barbe quelquefois
parce que on à ce moment là que de
mauvaises réactions ou bien on est
malheureux ou bien on essaie de s'en
sortir à tout prix et on devient
excessif on se met en colère où on se
met à ricaner bêtement
non non je sais c'est toujours très très
malheureux quand on est
et quand on a comme dit pierre mondy les
chaussettes qui tombe quoi enfin jean
loup dabadie vous allez me dire si j'ai
bien écouté tout ce que vous m'avez dit
je pense qu'il faut adorer le théâtre
pour en faire oui je pense que l'auteur
est moins vulnérable au cinéma qu'au
théâtre
oui ça mais c'est moins vrai maintenant
mais je dire oui peut-être parce que
c'est à dire qu'il est au théâtre il est
moins nombreux à se faire à se faire que
ray les cancans quand ça se passe mal
quand ça se compte une on dit qu'une
pièce est mauvaise on dit la pièce
d'intel émeutes tandis que au cinéma on
dit le film d'intel en citant le metteur
en scène et on associe éventuellement
dans le blâme les auteurs mais on prend
les mêmes responsabilités
la chanson est admis climat est ensuite
lancé m
c'est le vrai chemin de la satire oui
oui oui oui mais c'est le même chemin
qu'on retrouve qu'on doit retrouver
absolument théâtre ou qu'on retrouve
également au cinéma cas
là par exemple je vais après avoir fait
un nouveau film avec claude sautet vers
la fin de l'année je faire un film avec
françois truffaut nous avons déjà
commencé à parler tous les deux je me
rends compte que truffaut enfin je me
rends compte je n'ai pas besoin de
parler avec lui pour monde est rendu
compte dans ses films mais je veux dire
par là que va retrouver pendant
quelqu'un qui veut dire des choses et
veut dire des choses à des gens à
travers ses films donc je voulais le
chemin de la de la satire on le trouve
partout à condition qu'on soit bien
décidé à pas faire cette route
buissonnière justement jean loup dabadie
est ce qu'il ya des gens que vous
n'aimez pas ça existe
plus précisément il existe des façons
certaines gens que je n'aime pas vous
êtes un différend je m'exerce à l'être
je m'exerce mal je n'y arrive pas très
bien mais je fais des progrès
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas écrit un bon
livre parce que je ne suis pas un bon
romancier va jusqu'à présent du moins
les deux
roman que j'ai écrit quand les 19 et 20
ans était ce qu'on appelle au pire sens
du mot des petits romans c'est à dire
des petites histoires quand tout à
l'heure on
ben on parlait au passage de notre ami
paul guimard et écrire un livre quand
les choses de la vie c'est vrai on a
parlé des capacités policy cité joie
dans la balance il s'avoue la plaine la
peine de se déplacer jusqu'à sa table de
travail pour ça quand on parle de claude
néron ces livres sont tellement texan a
tellement important que bon alors moi je
peux vous dire que mémé livre n'était
pas bon d'abord parce que j'étais trop
petit oui à tout égard qu'une petite
histoire quand la petite histoire
d'amour qu'on raconte
je crois qu'il faudra que je prenne
quelques années avant de déjà maintenu m
non mais déjà maintenant si j'en avais
le temps je sais que ce sera évidemment
tout autre chose parce que j'ai vu
entendu regarder surtout beaucoup
d'autres choses à vis des diplômes au
départ oui une licence de lettres classé
latin du grec
la culture c'est quelque chose
d'important votre avis j'ai toujours
pensé que la culture de chacun doit
souffrir répété moi j'ai toujours dit
que la culture c'est un trousseau que
chacun doit s'offrir avec les voyez je
voulais moi si tu es françoise sagan au
jeu vous faire passer un test avant de
terminer mais alors ça va être très
rapide
qu'est ce que c'est il s'agit d' à
aspères qui décide un matin là mais son
fils à l'école
oui il part en voiture avec son fils un
feu rouge il le grille un accident le
père ait tué deux fils et une grièvement
blessée
on transporte le fils à l'hôpital une
intervention chirurgicale est nécessaire
et à ce moment là le chirurgien se
présenter 10 je ne veux pas opérer
monfils alors qui est sûre chirurgienne
qui est ce ce chirurgien
qu'est-ce que je dois répondre qui est
ce chirurgien voulait dire quel genre
d'homme c'est une devinette ou dance est
un test vous avez bien compris c'est
avec son fils
je crois que je n'ai pas bien compris
parce que j'ai
lâché entre l'accident et l'hôpital d'un
père qu'il a à travers avec son fils de
quatre ans pour l'école
oui il ya un accident le père ait tué le
fise est blessé on transporte le final
et le chirurgien a dit je ne peux pas
opérer de sa vie alors oui mais qu'est
ce chirurgien allez dire un personnage
de mauvais boulevard non par exemple non
les vagues ont pris car ce chirurgien
c'est sa mère ah oui et c'est très
important sur le grèce car les gens ne
répondent jamais c'est sa mère et cela
veut dire qu'ils sont à touche
antiféministe c'est vrai alors c'est un
secteur gentilly vous venez de me dire
on a terminé merci jean loup dabadie
[Musique]